>> Judge Jeanine: DANGEROUS
TIMES, THANKS SO MUCH.
WE WILL CHECK IN WITH YOU LATER
ON IN THE SHOW BUT JOINING ME
NOW IS NEWT GINGRICH, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND SPEAK OF THE
HOUSE.
WE WILL GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON
UKRAINE AND MOMENTS BUT FIRST,
LET'S GO BACK TO BIDEN'S KAMALA
PROBLEM.
HER POTENTIAL 2024 RIVALS MUST
BE LOVING THIS.
CAN YOU HEAR ME?
>> I COULD.
I WASN'T SURE WHETHER OR NOT YOU
WOULD SHOW HOW KAMALA IS
UNBELIEVABLE.
LOOK, I THINK WE HAVE NEVER SEEN
A NATIONAL POLITICAL FIGURE, NOT
JUST THE VICE PRESIDENT BUT A
NATIONAL POLITICAL FIGURE WHO IS
AS SELF-DESTRUCTIVE AS
KAMALA HARRIS?
YOU WATCH HER DAY AFTER DAY, YOU
WATCH HER GO TO POLAND AND BREAK
UP LAUGHING IN A PRESS
CONFERENCE WITH THE POLISH
PRESIDENT WHEN SHE IS ASKED
ABOUT THE REFUGEES FROM UKRAINE.
YOU SEE HER TENTH PERSON LEAVE
HER STAFF, WHO WAS BY THE WAY
THE NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR
WHO WAS WITH HER IN POLAND, WHO
MUST BEEN TOTALLY EMBARRASSED
AND DEMORALIZED BY WATCHING HER
BREAK UP LAUGHING WHEN TALKING
ABOUT THE UKRAINIAN REFUGEES.
AND YOU WATCH OTHER THINGS SHE'S
DONE, AND I THOUGHT THAT SHE WAS
AN INSURANCE POLICY TO MAKE SURE
THAT NOBODY TRIED TO REPLACE A
BIDEN MATTER HOW BAD HIS
COGNITIVE PROBLEMS BUT I'M
BEGINNING TO THINK THAT SHE IS
LIKE SPIRAL AGNEW WHO WAS SO
BAD, IT'S AT THE STAGE FOR NIXON
TO BE REPLACED.
I HAVE A HUNCH SHE IS A VERY,
VERY SHORT FUSE RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE I THINK MOST AMERICANS
REALIZE THAT THE PROSPECT OF HER
BEING PRESIDENT IS GENUINELY
TERRIFYING.
IT'S BAD ENOUGH TO THINK ABOUT
BIDEN BEING PRESIDENT WHEN HE IS
CLEARLY NOT TOTALLY IN TOUCH
WITH REALITY, BUT THE IDEA OF
BEING REPLACED BY KAMALA IS
ASTONISHINGLY FRIGHTENING.
>> Judge Jeanine: LET ME ASK
YOU THIS, IF SHE IS
VICE PRESIDENT LOOK AT THE
PRESIDENT -- FORGET BIDEN, ANY
PRESIDENT WITH A VICE PRESIDENT
LIKE THAT, WHAT WOULD THEY DO?
IS THERE ANOTHER PERSON WHO
WOULD PULL UP IN FRONT OF THE
NATION TO DELIVER ON SOME OF THE
ISSUES AMERICANS WANT TO HEAR
ABOUT?
WHAT DO YOU DO IN THIS
SITUATION?
>> THE FIRST THING YOU DO IS YOU
SEND HER TO THE NAVAL
OBSERVATORY WHICH IS THE HOME OF
THE VICE PRESIDENT AND YOU SAY,
PLEASE DON'T LEAVE FOR THE NEXT
THREE YEARS AND YOU OFFER HER
BOOKS AND MOVIES AND VIDEO GAMES
BUT YOU DON'T LET HER LEAVE.
THE SECOND THING I THINK YOU DO
IS YOU FIND SOMEBODY, WHETHER IT
IS SECRETARY OF STATE OR
SOMEBODY ELSE WHO YOU EMPOWER TO
GO AROUND THE WORLD AND PRETEND
THEY ARE YOU.
WHAT YOU DON'T ALLOW HER EVER
AGAIN TO LEAVE THE
UNITED STATES.
PEOPLE NEED TO REALIZE THIS
ISN'T JUST POLITICS, IT'S NOT
JUST FUNNY.
DO YOU HAVE ALL AROUND THE WORLD
WATCHING THE UNITED STATES BE
HUMILIATING ONLY INCOMPETENT.
AND I THINK IT IS A DRAMATIC
WOUND TO OUR POSITION IN THE
WORLD TO HAVE KAMALA HARRIS GO
ANYWHERE.
>> Judge Jeanine: I WANT TO
GET YOUR SENSE OF WHAT YOU THINK
PRESIDENT BIDEN WILL ACCOMPLISH
WHEN HE GOES TO EUROPE THIS
WEEK.
>> I THINK THE FIRST THING HE
OUGHT TO DO IS MAKE SURE THERE
ARE ANTISHIP MISSILES BEING SENT
UKRAINE RIGHT NOW.
I'VE NOT HEARD ANYBODY TALK
ABOUT THIS BUT THE FACT IS WHEN
YOU WATCH THE BLACK SEA FEET OF
THE RUSSIAN NAVY BOMBARDED THE
UKRAINIAN COAST, WE HAVE LOTS OF
MISSILES WHICH ARE CAPABLE OF
DESTROYING THOSE MISSILES AND
THEY SHOULD ALL BE IN THE HANDS
OF UKRAINIANS AND UKRAINIANS
OUGHT TO BE BASICALLY DESTROYING
THE BLACK SEA FLEET, WHICH WE
COULD DO.
WE HAVE THAT CAPACITY.
SECOND, I WANT TO KNOW WHETHER
OR NOT THE HIGH ALTITUDE
ANTIAIRCRAFT MISSILES WHICH
BIDEN PROMISED LAST WEEK ARE NOW
IN UKRAINE.
THIRD, BIDEN OUGHT TO SAY IF
PUTIN IS GOING TO ENGAGE IN A
POLICY OF KILLING CIVILIANS, AND
WE ARE GOING TO GIVE SURFACE TO
SURFACE MISSILES AND CRUISE
MISSILES TO UKRAINE SO THEY CAN
HAVE RUSSIAN AIRFIELDS AND A
RUSSIAN MISSILE BASES FIRING
INTO CIVILIANS.
WE DON'T HAVE TO ACCEPT SOME
DEAL WHERE RUSSIANS DON'T HAVE
TO FIGHT WHILE THEY REMAIN SAFE
BUT UKRAINIANS ONLY HAVE TO BE
IN DEFENSE.
I THINK WHEN SOMEBODY STARTS
KILLING YOUR WOMEN AND CHILDREN,
DESTROYING YOUR CULTURAL
HERITAGE, YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO
DEFEND YOURSELF BY TAKING OUT
THEIR AIRFIELDS AND THEIR
MISSILES.
FINALLY, HE OUGHT TO GO TO NATO
AND THE NUMBER ONE THING THEY
NEED TO AGREE ON IS A PUBLIC,
EXPLICIT COMMITMENT THAT IF
PUTIN GOES TO CHEMICAL WEAPONS
THEY WILL IMMEDIATELY WITHIN A
COUPLE OF HOURS DO EVERYTHING
THEY CAN TO DESTROY THAT
CAPABILITY.
THERE SHOULD BE NO CONFUSION
ABOUT NONE OF THIS.
EVENTUALLY THERE WILL BE
SANCTIONS, EVENTUA